chyna October 5th 2014 NASA's Landsat 8
orbits above one of the most extreme
deserts on earth its multispectral
camera captures an image of something
strange we're looking down on a very
remote part of the world a series of
irregular shaped dark patches marks the
land stir the sand for hundreds and
hundreds of models and yet there are
these dark patches I've never really
seen anything like this before this is
this is weird
Ralph Lorenz is one of the few
scientists to have braved by danger ins
harsh terrain and investigated the
phenomenon at ground level what he
discovers is quite extraordinary it's
hard work these are some of the tallest
students on earth and what's amazing is
when you climb up to the top you look
out and you see the sea lakes it's just
absurd you're in this desert area and
yet there are beautiful lakes in between
it's a spectacular place lakes in the
middle of the desert how is that even
possible it's just kind of a strange
location to see this many lakes spread
out in that area they're not fed by
rivers on the surface and not fed by
rainfall locally
any body of water in such a hot
environment should completely evaporate
this desert gets maybe 2 to 3 inches of
precipitation per year and in a desert
like this you can probably evaporate
maybe 40 to 50 times as much water in a
year and so it's not the place water
should hang out
the very existence of the lakes is not
the only mystery something very strange
about these lakes is that some are salty
some are fresh and it's sort of puzzling
but the presence of salt could be a clue
to the source for all this water means
water's coming from somewhere else and
the only place for it to come from is
underground research into this weird
landscape is ongoing but for now the
mysterious desert Lakes still pose
questions
you